(mysterious orchestral music)
(quiet chatter)
- [Man] Hey.
- [Woman] Hi.
- Uh, I was actually just leaving.
- Oh, it's fine.
- Okay, all right, bye.
(descending electrical surge)
- [Voiceover] Well, here you are.
Five minutes too long
on that conference call
and now you have to sit alone at lunch.
You could go back and eat at your desk,
but somehow, that's even worse.
And your usual lunch
partner's out with the boss.
(uproarious laughter)
Maybe if you stare at the
other table long enough,
they'll notice you.
- Anna, come pull up a
chair, we can make room.
No need to sit alone.
(women muttering)
- No, uh, it's okay, there's no room.
- No, we can make room.
(women muttering)
- We can't.
- [Voiceover] Well, that was humiliating.
- Did you guys see Game
of Thrones last night?
- Yes!
- [Voiceover] You saw Game
of Thrones last night.
You have something witty and
intelligent to say about it,
but that conversation is not for you.
You can't join from the
next table, that's pathetic.
Time to pretend there's
something really interesting
to look at on your phone,
nevermind you already checked
Facebook, Instagram and
Twitter 20 times today,
so there's nothing new.
What is it about eating
alone that makes you
feel like a loser?
No matter how old you get, no matter
how confident you are in yourself,
one empty table and it's like
high school all over again.
Oh, thank God. Oh, (bleep) you, guy.
- Is this seat taken?
- [Voiceover] You mean, is this seat taken
by anyone more interesting?
- All you.
- [Voiceover] Now you
have to make small talk
with someone you'd
never choose to eat with
under normal circumstances.
- [Man] So how's it going?
- [Woman] Good, good.
- [Voiceover] You can't even
remember this guy's name.
Ethan? Earl?
You know he works in the
cubicle across from you,
but beyond that, nothing.
- So, did you watch Game
of Thrones last night?
- Oh, no, I don't have HBO.
- [Voiceover] Of course he doesn't.
Heaven forbid he actually do something
to contribute to the conversation.
Now he's just gonna sit there
with his big stupid face
sucking on his big stupid sandwich.
Well, nothing left to do
now besides pick up the pace
and end this nightmare.
- Good salad, huh?
- [Woman] Mm hmm.
Well, back to the grind.
- [Man] Yeah.
Go get 'em, tiger.
- [Voiceover] Ah, thank God that's over.
Eating alone is the absolute worst.
- I like the part where
he's like, "And my axe."
- Okay, that's Lord of the Rings.
That's Lord of the--
(orchestra tuning note)